افاد مراسل الجزيره بوصول جثامين 14 شهيدا
الى مستشفى ناصر نتيجه القصف الاسرائيلي
على مدينه خان يونس منذ صباح اليوم واضاف
ان اليات الاحتلال اطلقت النار على منازل
في محيط المجمع كما واصل قناصه جيش
الاحتلال استهداف المواطنين والنازحين في
مراكز الايواء داخل المدينه بدوره افاد
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطينيه ان قوات
الاحتلال اطلقت النار على مباني الجمعيه
ومستشفى الامل في خان يونس اقتادت المدير
العام والمدير الاداري للمستشفى الى جهه
مجهوله في غضون ذلك يستمر القصف
الاسرائيلي لمناطق متفرقه في قطاع غزه وقد
شيع اهالي دير البلح جثامين 14 شهيدا صباح
اليوم من امام مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وسط
قطاع غزه وافاد مراسل الجزيره بارتفاع عدد
الشهداء في دير البلح الى 30 خلال الساعات
الارب
الماضيه بعد قصف اسرائيلي جديد استهدف
منطقه
الزوايده
اعيدها ايدك
ح ساعدوني وطلع عليا يلا يلا واحد يدي ه
من يلا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يلا جنبك انا يا م جنب شايف اي
شي
يلا يا
علي اصر عليها
[موسيقى]
ا خليك يا
عميه
ابعد هيك ابعد ه اوع
اوع تعال
تعال الجراحه سكر سكر سكر سكر
الباب يلا
هذا كمان على
الجراحه
[موسيقى]
والله
ب